turn I'm book TV have corporate interest
overtaken state priorities as the
driving force behind developing world
conflicts next on book TV Brookings
Institution security analyst pw singer
considers the military-industrial
complex and his new book corporate
warriors it's an hour well thank you
very much for having me here in
particular it's great to join an
audience of Prince Tony ins I'm a little
bit fearful of the questions during the
Q&A I'll have to admit on this week I've
given talks to senior military officers
folks from the New York Times and folks
from Congress but I'm I think folks from
Princeton are going to add a little bit
tougher ones today I'd like to talk to
you about what I think is a new and
unique business forum it's called the
privatized military firm and I think
it's fascinating but it also has some
pretty serious implications for security
politics and economics actually if I can
ask that just the the projector there be
turned off I don't think we're going to
be able to boot up the stuff in the
middle of the talk here now privatized
military firms or what I call p.m. f's
are defined as business providers of
professional services intricately linked
to warfare their corporate bodies that
specialize in the provision of military
skills and services now this means they
do everything from conduct tactical
combat operations strategic planning
intelligence operation and logistics
troop training troop recruiting
technical assistance the whole array of
military skills and what the rise of
this industry means is that now any
military skill set can be accessed by
simply writing a check now the activity
and impact of this industry is often
quite under realized given that a lot of
people haven't even heard that it
existed in the last decade these firms
have been active in zones of conflict
and transition across the entire globe
alphabetically they've operated from
Albania to Zambia in terms of strategic
importance they've operated in places
like East Timor they've also operated in
the Persian Gulf in terms of rich versus
poor they've operated in the poorest of
states like congo brazzaville and
they've operated in the riches of state
like saudi arabia but most importantly
the u.s. itself is the largest single
client of this industry in fact since
1994 we've signed over 3,000 contracts
with this industry now this industry has
been driven by three factors it's rise
since the end of the Cold War's been
driven by three factors the first is
essentially a shift in the supply and
demand forces of security at that point
on one side the supply side you had
massive military downsizing around the
globe you have about 6 million less
soldiers in the world right now than you
had during the Cold War and this
downsizing also happened within the US
military which is about forty percent
smaller than that period that not only
shifted the labor market but also at the
same time you had a rise in demand for
professional forces you had more and
more conflicts around the globe and
looking at the u.s. itself we deployed
to a number of places that you never
would have predicted starting in the
early 90s from Somalia Haiti Bosnia
Kosovo Central Asia and now to Iraq so
what it means is that at a time of
diminished supply you have increased
demand and the private market has rushed
to fill that space now the second force
is technologic it's what a lot of people
call the revolution of military affairs
and what it essentially sums up is a
shift in the use of technology and
warfare not only a greater reliance on
it but a greater reliance on civilian
technology unlike during World War two
for example where it was the military
developing most of the technology now
our military is pulling much of its
advanced technology off the civilian
market and so it's bringing civilian
technicians to help run it in particular
we've seen the use of information
technology to help make our weapons more
lethal during the Iraq war and then
finally is an economic ideology shift
basically it's called
the privatization revolution and it's
this belief that's taken off over the
last couple decades about the government
versus the marketplace in terms of
efficiency basically it's a belief that
the government is inherently less
efficient than the private marketplace
and therefore you should turn over
whatever roles you can to it and we've
seen it in all kind of spheres we've
seen it in private prisons private
school vouchers private garbage
collection Morris spent on private
security in the u.s. right now than is
spent on RF police forces and now we've
seen it move over into warfare itself so
the result is this massive shift towards
this industry and as an example if there
was any conflict that would have seemed
to have been a essential public US
military conflict it would have been our
response to September 11th our
deployment into Afghanistan all the
previous concerns that we'd had in the
90s about concerns over casualties for
example had fallen by the wayside you
had a clearly unified American public
and support of this operation and yet
during this operation private military
firms were all over the place there are
among the very first troops on the
ground deploying within the CIA
paramilitary units that arrived even
before our Green Berets did they served
on our surveillance and targeting
aircraft they provided logistic support
and even some weapon systems such as the
globe denoted Global Hawk which was this
latest generation unmanned aerial
vehicle was not only maintained by
private government by private employees
it was actually operated by private
employees in the follow-on
anti-terrorist operations around the
globe private companies have played a
similar range of roles for example
helping with training in the Philippines
former Soviet state of Georgia they've
also for example run similar operations
in Colombia likewise if you were unlucky
enough to be a member of the Taliban or
al-qaeda that was captured by our forces
you could plan on spending the rest of
your days at a military prison in
Guantanamo Bay Cuba that was actually
built not by the US military but by
Halliburton Brown & Root it's in essence
the Halliburton hotel
perhaps no example though illustrates
the industry's growing activity than the
recent war against Iraq before the war
private companies helped with the
planning and wargaming and training of
the invasion itself during the war they
ran the supply chain they helped
maintain some of our most sophisticated
weapon systems during that period
ranging from the b-2 stealth bomber to
the f-117 stealth fighter they also
served and operated several weapon
systems for example onboard US Navy
guided missile destroyers running their
air defence networks indeed the ratio of
private contractors to US military
personnel was one contractor for every
ten personnel and it wasn't just the US
military that was relying on these but
our allies for example the Australians
and the British also outsource their
logistics to them during the current
occupation period their role in scope is
even greater private companies are
helping with the training of the
post-saddam police the posted on
paramilitary forces and the post-saddam
army indeed if you look at the exact
troop numbers private military employees
are actually our largest ally in the
Coalition of the Willing so in many ways
we should actually rename it the
coalition of the billing as an example
just one firm global wrists has 1,100
personnel on the ground in Iraq has
around 100 x British special forces 500
Nepalese Gurkha fighters and 500
soldiers from Fiji that makes global
risks 6 in the overall ranking of
members of the of the coalition and this
doesn't even include the over 2 billion
dollars we've given to the Halliburton
firm to do military and now oil services
and a lot of people are familiar with
that firm of course because it's vice
president Cheney's old business so
looking at this globally this industry
is one of the few that's done well after
September 11th indeed on average the
stock prices in it have gone up by fifty
percent which compares pretty good to
what my portfolio did after September
11 and indeed if you were lucky enough
to have invested in certain firms within
it it might have doubled for example l3
is a company which owns em PRI which is
a military consulting firm it's doubled
since then so overall we have an
industry that's doing about a hundred
billion dollars in global annual revenue
and most people haven't even heard of it
let alone thinking about the role that
it plays that's so important security
itself now not all of these firms look
alike and nor do they serve the same
market so really an important challenge
for me in writing this book was to try
and figure out what is the structure
within this industry and the way I think
about it is that you have to accept it
for what its fundamentals are it's both
military in essence but it's also
business in essence so you have to sort
of layer it out that way and essentially
it divides into three core sectors and
the metaphor to think about it in terms
of military thought is what they call
the tip of the spear metaphor where
units within militaries are thought of
in different ways by their location in
the battle space by how far they are
from the front lines in turn there is a
similar parallel in the outsourcing
industry the general outsourcing and
their connection to the customer
themselves and so that essentially
divides into three types of companies
the first type are called military
provider firms and you'll often hear
these called private military companies
as well or pmcs these are companies that
provide combat services themselves
they're at the forefront of the battle
space and the classic one that I talk
about in the book is executive outcomes
which is this interesting South African
firm it was staffed by africanus who
could no longer work for their
government after Nelson Mandela took
over so their battalion essentially
privatized itself and went on the open
market to work the second type of
company are called military consulting
firms and there are a lot like regular
consulting firms they won't do the job
for you they won't fight for you but
they'll train it advise you to do the
job better and the classic example there
it's a company called military
professional
resources incorporated that's actually
here in Virginia and is actually the one
that I first came into contact with
writing my senior thesis this company is
made up of X u.s. u.s. army sergeants
and officers all the way up to four star
general level has about a thousand
people active in the field right now in
a database of another 14,000 who've said
they've they're willing to work for this
company if they're called upon the third
type are called military support firms
and basically they're akin to supply
chain management firms they don't run
your essential activity but they run
other activities that helps you carry it
out and the classic example there is
Halliburton and it's Kellogg Brown and
Root on the division which I have a
whole chapter on in the in the company
I'm in the in the book and basically it
handles military logistics right now now
the last area that I'd like to talk
about is what are the implications of
this industry and essentially in the
book I sort of divided it down into a
number of issue areas but they really
fall into three areas the first is the
introduction of business contracting and
contractual dilemmas into warfare the
second is the possibility of market
dynamics and market disruptions on
things like international security and
human rights and then the third is what
happens when you have public policy
carried out by private means now the
first one is I think the one that's
getting the most attention now
particularly in what's going on in Iraq
and the issues over contracting there
and really what it comes down to is
divided loyalties and goals at the end
of the day the question is whether the
public good and the private good are
perfectly aligned and of course they
aren't always perfectly aligned so the
core interest of the company at the
bottom line is its bottom line its
profit maximization so while the
companies may say well we would only do
what's in the public's best interest or
we would only do what's in our clients
best interests the key is that the
person and the entity making the
decision over what is that besant
interest has been moved outside the
operation it's been moved from
government into the company so that
realized that that causes a certain
dilemma in some situations you get great
services from a good corporate citizen
who can specialize in that service and
provide a certain amount of expertise at
a lower rate however you also have the
risk of bad corporate citizens in
regular industry the example to think
about is that for every Ben & Jerry's
you run the risk of also having an Enron
only here the stakes are far far higher
so the difficulty with private military
companies is that you have to find a way
to lock in a critical service national
security itself without losing the
efficiency of the marketplace so you
have all the normal worries that you
have with regular contracting if you
were to hire a plumber for example you
have to worry about overbilling over
staffing what's the quality of service
that they're going to provide you but
now it's taking place within warfare and
so these normal worries still happen on
the classic example of this took place
with the company called dyncorp that's
based here in Virginia as well they had
contracts in the Balkans where not only
were they supposed to provide
international police but they are also
doing maintenance on u.s. army aircraft
their employees in many cases were
reportedly ex waiters ex security guards
basically people who weren't trained to
the level that they were billing for
this was an accusation made by a another
employee within the firm in addition
several members of that firm got
involved in some pretty vicious sex
crimes while they were under US
government employee that included their
site supervisor videotaping himself
raping two young women none of those
employees who committed those crimes
have been criminally prosecuted because
of an unclear status of these employees
but still this is how we've been
represented on the ground so it gets
even worse when you add in the fact that
our oversight is minimal over these
companies
as an example the Pentagon right now
simply does not know the exact number of
private military employees it has
working for it in the Gulf so you can't
claim to have either good policy nor
good business if you don't even know how
many employees you have working for you
another example is the no bid process
that we've had with the Halliburton oil
contract where we took what was a
competitively bid military logistics
contract and then added on a non bid oil
support services portion of it so we
didn't get the best deal here now this
is in terms of sort of financing and
cost savings and in terms of accounting
but what concerns me i think and more is
what happens if the outsourcing company
fails in its job or decides that the
contract is no longer in its best
interests by moving the operation to an
outside entity force commanders lose
control over the success and failure of
their own operation they lose a critical
insurance policy now this holds true
whether you're talking about weak states
for example the government of Sierra
Leone hired a company of Gurkha fighters
their mission commander was killed in an
ambush and then cannibalized by local
rebels and so the company said were out
of here and Sierra Leone was left
without an army during that period but
this concern also should trouble us from
the perspective of the world's largest
superpower because one of the issues in
Iraq right now is our reliance on
technicians and logisticians who are not
bound by military law and thus cannot be
ordered either into a combat zone or
ordered to stay within a combat zone and
the attrition rate of the contractors
right now is something that's worrisome
and when you hear these complaints about
our soldiers in the field not getting
the service and support that they got in
previous Wars still eating field ration
months after you know President Bush's
infamous aircraft carrier landing still
not having running water part of that is
because of contractors and this over
outsourcing but there's another aspect
here another loss of your insurance
policy is that by outsourcing your
support you lose the ability to shift
forces
in two different roles you lose the
ability for example to order support
troops to pick up a gun and go to the
front line when the going gets tough now
a great example of this was the Battle
of the Bulge during World War two where
in the classic story we're about to lose
this critical battle and General
Eisenhower says every cook every typist
every truck driver pick up your rifle
and go to the front and that helped turn
the tide of battle when you have
contractors you can't do that not only
because they you can't order them in
some cases they might not be trained to
be and in other cases their foreign
because you're using foreign
subcontractors now some people say well
that's 1944 that doesn't apply anymore
you know were the preponderance
superpower we don't have to worry about
things like this well actually during
the battle of mogadishu the Black Hawk
Down scenario that everyone remembers it
was support troops who went out there
and rescued those Rangers if that
incident happened today they would not
have anyone to go out and rescue them
now similar there's another security
concern that comes into this which is
infiltration that this risk is
heightened in the search for efficiency
for example private military companies
may have an incentive to cut corners to
add to profits one example was a company
that took over our aerial intelligence
and surveillance gathering in the
Balkans in a cutting corner it didn't
encrypt it's live video feed so if you
were in Europe during this period you
could watch live footage of American
special forces carrying out war criminal
and air any terrorists rates as long as
you just had a satellite dish by
comparison you couldn't tap into the
Disney Channel there's another risk of
infiltration uh in Afghanistan an
al-qaeda terrorists tried to infiltrate
one of our contracted field kitchens
fortunately that was caught but the plot
there was to poison our troops from
within unfortunately there was another
incident in the first week of the Iraq
war that wasn't caught where a foreign
subcontractor inside a US base camp Doha
which was the main base in the war was
unhappy about the conflict got in his
truck inside our base and drove into a
line of 82nd airborne pair
trooper sending 15 to the 15 of them to
the hospital so my ultimate point here
is that sometimes military organizations
are inefficient for a very good reason
and war leaner is not always better now
the second area and I'm going to try and
go through these a little bit quicker
because I think it's more important to
have some discussion here but the second
area is that private military firms are
now relevant actors within warfare
business is a relevant actor with in
warfare and it's a global industry we're
talking about an industry that not only
operates in over 50 different countries
but is based around the globe and so
that means that it's up to the company's
not only who works for them but who they
work for and so while you have some
companies that decide that it's in their
profit interests to work for the good
guys they work for democracies they work
for humanitarian groups they work for
environmental groups you have other
companies that decide there's money to
be made working for the bad guys and you
know an appropriate parallel here is the
legal trade where you have some people
who do pro bono work and some people who
specialize in defending drug kingpins
well within the private military
industry we've had private military
firms work for drug kingpins we saw
offer we sorry we've also had private
military firms work for rebel groups and
also work with al-qaeda-linked terrorist
groups the other aspect that's
interesting and perhaps troubling is the
effect on human rights within a conflict
you have dueling incentive structures
there on one hand a company may want to
be known as a good corporate citizen or
they may want to be known as a company
that gets the job done and so we've had
several and Senate several incidents
where there have been kind of troubling
on occurrences for example in Colombia
1998 where a village was mistakenly
bombed because of instructions given by
a private military firm and over 18
unarmed civilians were killed or as you
may recall there was a planeload of
American missionaries that was shot down
in Peru the plane that gave that
mistaken order was also a contracted on
private military firms Lane the final
area is
introduction of alternative policy
agents into policymaking basically it's
carrying out policy by private means and
so you have a third party into the civil
military apparatus so not only does this
get in the way of the relations was
between soldiers and the state and in
some cases local soldiers don't like
having better paid Outsiders come in one
incident that was sparked was an army
mutiny in Papua New Guinea but also you
have the fact that private military
companies are used to carry out
operations for which you couldn't get
public approval it's used as a way to
get around congressional restrictions
and the example there of course is
Colombia where right now we have at
least I think seven different private
military firms on the ground engaged in
the Civil War and counter-narcotics work
and the reason is because of troop caps
and also that we don't want to have any
kind of incidents make the press back
here what's happened is that when it
goes awry government is able to shift
blame and avoid that and we actually
have three American private military
employees who are held captive right now
by the FARC rebels they were with a
company called California microwave
systems and what's interesting is this
is this what is their status are they
POWs or have they been kidnapped well
they were carrying out a military
mission but on the other hand they were
not US military employees and so the
irony is that we now have over 50 US
army troops out hunting to try and
rescue these three private military
contractors and i should add the irony
by that i mean is that it's twofold one
the original rationale for using these
private military contractors was so that
our army guys wouldn't be exposed to
danger and to these army guys are of
course paid much much less than the
private military guys are trying to
rescue so in ending here the concept of
private military firms sounds like
something out of a Hollywood movie and
if I given this talk 10 years ago you
would have said that is a great work
and that is a great novel but it is a
reality right now and what's unfortunate
is that the issues of accounting and
accountability still haven't been worked
out despite the fact that we've had so
many we've had thousands of contracts
and billions of dollars spent on these
firms and so at the end of the day until
we catch up to this industry it's the
only way that we will be able to
establish that the public profits from
this privatization rather than just the
companies thank you why don't we just do
a QA and just raise your hands and I'll
i guess point out and just give me a sec
right there next up in class of 75 my
point is momentary journalists and for
more interesting news was a u.s. naval
officer your comment about if you had
set this ten years ago it would have
been viewed as scientific science
fiction our challenger asked a couple of
questions 1981 and since died when on a
frigate USS employed 200 sailors five
tech reps from the civilian firms at the
same time any of our aircraft carriers
deploying routinely had
hundred civilian tech reps maybe there
were a few more on the category of today
friends of mine at that time got out of
the military in the early 80s could
recall finding letters occasionally or
ads in and some people might say soldier
of fortune is an off-the-wall magazine
well interestingly enough some of the
ads were for companies that were
advertising to get what was the term
they used them soldiers of fortune of
mercenaries for Nicole Nicaragua South
Africa el salvador Rhodesia so is this
truly something okay it's expanding
perhaps perhaps it expanded because in
the 1990s we had a desire on the part of
the administration to go into more
places and not be willing to bear the
possible cost in terms of us lives so is
it a case of private industry stepped in
with the administration was jumping
ahead and it there always been these
firms on the outside and then now
they're merely moving in rather than
it's something good and you it's a
really good question and actually one of
the things I think is most fascinating
about this is the history of it because
when we take a step back and take a
broad lens view you know not just in
terms of past decades but in terms of
centuries when you look at warfare
itself we often assume that it's a story
of men in uniform fighting for the
political cause of their nation state
but actually that is the exception in
the last several millennium of warfare
private entities have played a role
across it whether you're talking about
mercenary bands that were hired out
during the Roman Empire period of the
free companies during the Middle Ages
the condo thierry that Machiavelli
writes about
I shouldn't passion mercenaries who
participate in the Battle of Princeton
to the East India Trading companies that
ran essentially India and had their own
army now what's different though is what
we're seeing is a shift starting with
the rise in the nation state that trade
that in ability for private companies to
participate in warfare was forced out of
the marketplace and the only way that it
existed was on the black market so to
speak it was individualized and it was
under the table that's the mercenaries
that's the the dogs of war and really
the period of the 60s is sort of the
classic time of that we're private
groupings of mercenaries are ad hoc
they're not they're not existent in
corporate structures the way they are
now they're not public they have to keep
it hidden because it's considered
illegal so when they recruit the
recruiting is done in terms of veiled
references for example madmike [ __ ]
one of the ones who is active in Congo
when he recruited his he put up things
in the classified ads it would say you
know able-bodied young men looking for
adventure call to this number well now
these are corporatized structures
they're publicly traded they're open
they're found to be legal they're not ad
hoc they're operating all over the globe
and a big difference with mercenaries is
not only are they operating in more than
one place at one time but they're also
providing the full range of services all
the way from supply up to fighting for
you you never had a company in the past
that could offer out a battalion of
commandos as a to make the comparison
for example with the Hessians was they
were from the government of Hesse it was
the way that the king of Hesse paid for
his it was he was renting his own army
it was not an independent corporate
structure that was renting itself out
now the comparison though with role of
private contractors within the US
military in the past really goes to an
issue of size and scope first is the
numbers are just incredibly different um
for example during the first Gulf War
the ratio of private contractors was one
to a hundred
we're now at 1 to 10 so it's a tenfold
increase in a decade but more important
to me is what are the roles that these
contractors are playing in the past the
doctrine was that a contractor could
never run a mission critical activity
likewise when we talked about
maintenance the old rule was that
contractors could only provide services
for the first year of a new weapon being
introduced to the force and after that
year our forces had to learn how to run
and operate it and repair it ourselves
now we've turned that on its head where
we have lifetime support when whenever a
new weapon system is delivered the
company is expected to do the
maintenance of it and actually what
we're seeing now is the company is now
taking over the operation of it and so
you know when we lay out all these range
of roles it's just a big sea change in
what's going on there's a history to it
but it's incredibly different and I
think we need for law and regulation to
catch up to it i'm jim Hughson from the
class of 69 I'm a retired Marine Colonel
and I guess I'm the CEO of a company
that fits into the second class
just manager a consultant my wife told
me I had to take it easy rather than say
you have no context which I'd love to
take you out but why not just ask you
this it sounds like you're advocating
for a larger military because you're
describing a situation where many roles
that you seem to be saying the military
used to do or should do are now being
contracted out so are you saying we need
a bigger military and all those services
that need to be done should have stayed
as military functions there's two parts
soon it's a really good question um the
first is we're talking about a global
industry so a lot of what's driving it
isn't just our own military's needs
it'sit's changes in the conflict
environment out there and that's one of
the reasons why we need why I advocate
better regulation of it regulation is
one of the things on a global level for
example we need to be able to establish
what are the legitimate companies and
what are the legitimate companies when
you have vetting of that we need to have
established rules for what their status
is it's not only good for the companies
in their contractors but it's also good
for us so that we have a way to ensure
accountability when things go wrong now
in looking at the US military itself I
often hear this and when you talk with
military folks and it's really what's
been driving it is look we are stretched
so thin right now that we don't have a
choice well actually we do have a choice
and there's layers of choices when that
one of those choices might be if you
expect to meet all these commitments
around the world you've got to make an
open and honest decision on whether
you're going to do things like expand
the force user reserves more or use
contractors more and the first step in
that deciding that decision is to decide
whether those commitments are necessary
or not the second step is if you decide
the commitment is worth it which is the
proper role for it to take for example
identify
what roles are too important to turn
over the private market that you can't
depend on them only then once you
determine that yes it is appropriate to
turn it over to a private contractor
then you need to establish rules and
mechanisms to ensure accounting and
accountability and you need to ensure
good accounting and competition so that
you're saving money right now we we have
an amended competition within the within
the sphere so we're using the private
market but we're using it in such a way
that it's not good business practice in
some cases we're awarding contracts to
politically connected firms with minimal
competition and so the result is it
instead of getting business efficiency
we're creating a monopoly for ourselves
so really it comes down to having good
accounting and good accountability and
then if you have that then yeah it gives
you greater leverage but there's a layer
of decisions and awareness that we need
to take to us the biggest issue is
transparency doesn't have good account
I don't think there's anybody and it's
shocking for such a CEO run institution
and you'd like to change but I just want
to say one more thing for I let you go
which is that you i think overly glibly
step over into saying well these
companies will not only pump your
gasoline or delivery or food we built
through your fight that's a gross
overstatement might be the company's
particularly American companies that are
doing the kind of support that you're
talking about Iraq and other places are
doing combat service support functions
they're doing you know they're providing
food gasoline available health care
system support mechanism they're not
doing work late and it's a gross
overstatement to say that they are I
think we're really we have to realize
that we're talking about an overall
industry it's like talking about the
outsourcing industry and focusing on a
McKinsey and saying well in the entire
world of outsourcing Mackenzie is the
model only sourcing companies only do
advising and strategic analysis well
that's clearly not the way it is in the
regular outsourcing industry for example
where I work Brookings we have a company
that comes in and runs our IT services
we have another company that comes in
and runs our cafeteria the same is in
the on the ground in Iraq you do have
companies one company that's providing
military training another company that's
providing paramilitary units another
company that's providing feeding and
housing our troops you have another
company that's got 1100 armed personnel
it's got two battalions on the ground
providing military essentially infantry
type roles on the ground and one of the
reasons is they're filling that space
and you know we can we can I would argue
the brookings dr to do policy of my
private means
yeah I guess you know it there's often
pushed back one of the other directions
on the pushback is look we're just
security firms we're private security
firms that's often a self-identification
that's with the firm's that admit to
having armed troops they say we only
come in and defend an installation and
that's a bit of a misnomer because we're
not talking about security in the sense
of your rent a cop at the local mall
you're talking about having a company of
trained commandos with ak-47s and
machine guns who are on a regular basis
right now in Iraq for example one of the
companies i spoke with you know they say
pretty much daily we're getting hit with
mortar rounds and machine-gun fire and
sniper fire older if you don't want a
little rolls privatized if that's if
that's if you've made the commitment
then you have to decide how to meet it
and really we have to face up to the
dilemmas we've created for ourselves
cost for the cost savings of doing this
privately you're doing military
operations privately versus through the
military and related to that you are
saying that one of the reasons that the
military says they need these
contractors is that they're stretched so
thin is this really a cost savings for
them right there were some different
kind of view of the budgeting process
that'd be and why is it that way they
think they can save money back yeah the
cost savings issue is I think an
important one and it's because there's
really not good data on it we've entered
into this scope of contracts and yet
there's still no evidence to show great
cost savings on a broad level it's only
we just have postcards and in some cases
their predictive that do show cost
savings looking forward if we do
outsource this we will save X amount in
some cases they're looking backwards
saying we save this here and in other
cases they've shown non cost savings for
example there was analysis of the razzi
program the Roxy program at over 200
American University has been privatized
and Iran study of that found that it
didn't save money so that's actually one
of the things that we need to undertake
is a good accounting of it you know we
can't even begin to purport if we have
cost savings we don't even know the
number of people working for us so that
would help clarify the issue and help us
make good decisions about it now there's
a couple dynamics there that we do know
are not helping cost-saving the first is
not having good free market competition
we clearly need a better bidding process
for a lot of these contracts because
it's not the fact that it's private that
saves you money it's the fact that it's
private and has to compete against other
firms and thus lower its price that
saves you money the other part of it is
you have to factor in your in your
original investments one of the
interesting things that's going on here
is that remember we're providing the
human capital in this relationship we're
training up the employees and then
they're entering the private market and
we're being billed for that training so
while it may appear to be cost savings
in the short term if you spread it out
it might factor out differently and then
the final thing to think about is one of
the real sort of rationales for
outsourcing is the idea that you know
maybe I'm paying more for them on a
short-term basis but I can hire and fire
them and only use them when I need them
you know yeah I pay these guys twice the
rate that I do US army folks but I don't
have to feed a housing fern I mean just
you i'm using the
Louis rain in some cases it's 10 how
many but I you know i'm only paying for
them a portion out of the year but again
if we're moving to a situation where
we're having greater and greater and
longer contracts you know for example
the original idea of the bosnia contract
was supposed to be a year it's still
going on now so you have to you have to
be honest with yourself there and and
similar and looking forward in Iraq we
have to admit that while we're
identifying these short-term contracts
their long-running contracts um just
right there yeah piata welcome from the
Old Europe
the American and I have to question the
first one concerns the fact that this
model luckily be used very powerfully as
a leverage for the poorest old europe
country which could leverage esteem i
didn't see a fighting force there as we
all know we got me these added to go for
because the media principles to army but
they put themself I an army so my first
question is are there other geographical
areas in the world where you have a
tendency to actually buy yourself an
army first one second question is more
of an ethical question one of the
previous evenings concerned the
diffusion of war the Western Way and an
interesting point for me was the [ __ ]
war was define or was perceived or lived
in the past as really a knack of
tremendous violence where you send
people to die to defend your country of
civilization your nation whatever it is
you want to define and die for but you
actually are sending your your
citizenship season airy to be killed the
more logically higher that essentially
by fighting forces then for me the whole
ethical issue of what does it mean
somebody's dying on the battlefield well
the guy his job you know you could pay
so you have not in your three dimensions
I have found a lack of an issue of
ethical questions you doesn't mean I old
European is a big old crap pattern but
that's my question sure well that's the
problem of trying to you know some up a
280 page book and 20 minutes so not to
where there was a whole chapter on the
ethics of this um I'm just going to go
through your your questions at first was
the idea of lesser states using this as
leverage and again it's a global
industry and so that means it's moving
capabilities on to the global market and
in some cases these are better
capabilities an example of Europe using
this is European states have not made
the same investments in their militaries
that the US has and one of the key
things that they lack is logistics and
air transport they have now contracted
that off the market actually from a
Ukrainian company to Ukrainian company
that flew the European portion of the
NATO peacekeepers to Afghanistan and
back and as they've delayed buying their
latest their own cargo ships it's this
same company that's filling that space
and this company's made I think it's 800
million dollars so far again it was
supposed to be a short-term contract but
it's turned out to be very very
lucrative for this firm but it also
affects really weak states out there in
different ways one of the things that
are write about is how it changes
alliance relationships one of the you
used to have the relationship between
rich and poor states where we would send
advisers and the local state would be
dependent on us for those advisers and
the skills that they would provide well
now small states can get their advisers
from elsewhere for example Papua New
Guinea is this state that there were
used to rely on Australia for its
military advice and Australia would say
ok there are certain things that we're
going to teach you and there's certain
things that we not and there's certain
skills you know for example you can only
they would only allow them to have
unarmed helicopters well in 1997 the
government of Papua New Guinea said
we're tired of this they're not going to
give us what we need to win our Civil
War we're going to get it off the
private market and they hired from the
sand line company a team of 80 commandos
and to a helicopter gunships so this was
a way they got out of it um but also it
means that this also affects the way
that on the risks of war because
essentially you can transform your
plowshares into swords much much quicker
and an example of that is um ethiopia
eritrea they had a war in the late 90s
Ethiopia least a wing of su-27 fighter
jets these are the Russian
equivalent of our f15 they not only
least the planes they leased the pilots
and the mission planners and the
technicians so basically Ethiopia very
poor state created an Air Force for
itself in a matter of weeks so it shifts
some of the relations there now the
ethics thing it's really cuts to the
heart of it and that's been one of the
problems with a mercenary trade in the
past is that people argue well this is
different from soldiers because the
mercenary trade is actually reliant on
the existence of war itself the ongoing
nature of war itself for their trade but
these guys push back and say you know
face reality war is out there if we ever
entered a period where peace broke out
you know great we'll lose our jobs but
that's not going to happen but really
what it comes down to in my mind is a
difference between ends and means you
know are you concerned about the ends of
your policy or the means of it and I
think a great illustration of the
dilemmas of this and it'll show that you
know in some ways you know I'm not
bashing these companies because one of
the things that's been discussed is use
of them for private peacekeeping and
this great example is the rwanda
genocide where the international
community and the US were unwilling to
go in and save people civilians that
were dying a private company said we
will go in put 1500 armed troops on the
ground and stop the genocide probably
would have saved in the tens of
thousands or somewhere around 200,000
somewhere in that period they the catch
though as they said we need 150 million
dollars and no one step forward to do it
so you know which would it have been a
better in to have these guys go in there
probably but no one was comfortable with
the means so I think it's a real
complicated relationship there back
there my name is Kelly Cooley armor
thousand forty so I was in the last
World War two
and I'm with this person on Old Europe
as i was in the army they were told that
one man shooting another man would be
one infantryman and there were nine men
behind him we never shot a rifle and
they will supposedly supply medics
quartermaster or two heavy artillery
tanks very ugly and they weren't in the
combat units now if that is true then we
are paying for these private source
companies for taking risks plus I
assumed in guerrilla warfare as we have
no right we have all these rear echelon
guys getting shot and not the combat
guys in the front line and so you're
getting a lot of these national guard
units and reserve troops were getting
killed and we're getting a daily
casually list on that so if that's the
case what do we paint while we paying
for risk-taking or we faced with skilled
of the job itself and if we're paying
for risk-taking there's no nobility to
warfare there's no courage no bravery
involved it's just going out and doing
your job and that's the case by we pay
for it and that's it's a completely
mercenary operation and that's what
would come you to it morphing well it's
a really good point because if this is
if military service is not the sort of
ultimate public service then I'm not
sure what is I mean there's really not
much left there and there's a number of
things that come up in your point the
first is right now the rear area in
essence doesn't exist within the battle
space it exists but it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist in the terms of a safe
rear area with the use of weapons of
mass destruction terrorism etc everybody
is at risk in that in that realm exactly
I mean it's still and so the concept
that you can divide you know an
outsourced out some
safe areas and non-essential rolls just
doesn't hold any more and one of the
interesting things right now on the
accounting side is not only in terms of
you know how many people are out there
working for us how much money have we
saved or not safe but also we don't know
how many have been killed unofficially
media reports reveal that it's at least
five in Iraq but it may be more we just
don't know because it doesn't go to the
official tally of it the other part that
you talk about is paying for risk-taking
and that does factor into this industry
and one of the interesting things is
that the market reacts to that and so
you know one of the contractors um that
is in Colombia right now tells how he's
being offered twice his current pay to
go to Iraq because it's considered a
much more dangerous zone which is you
know surprising to consider Colombia
safe in the first place so you have a
market that reacts to security which is
quite different than you know your
military doesn't react to the security
risk and so the attrition rate is
different for the contractors than it is
for the public for the reservist or the
army guys the rumor mill is that the
attrition rate is around thirty percent
basically contractors who get there and
decide that what they're being paid is
not worth it and they want to go home it
may be higher it may be a little lower
that's what the rumor mill is we don't
know the exact numbers and that's why
I'd be nice to know that but we do know
the attrition rate among US military
folks which is zero because they don't
have that choice I'm not surprised my
question oh that's okay it's tough he'll
forgive you robbery crown but you see
him take issue with the monopoly is
called by Halliburton I'm a bit confused
as to whether they won that monopoly
through a bidding process or whether it
was just awarded and if as as I imagine
they bid for the monopoly isn't there a
valid argument to be made for a certain
economies of scale if not if you have a
better argument how would you divide up
those those roles you know what if
you're north-south type thing would it
be a task issue or it's it's really this
is the sort of heart of the controversy
in DC right now and it's mainly because
of the identity of the company
Halliburton and so it of course quickly
takes on a partisan edge to it but it's
not just a Halliburton issue it's across
the way our government and other
governments have dealt with this
industry and that they often have not
had a full bidding process they'll
essentially hand over a certain role to
a company without exploring what are the
other options out there now the story of
the Halliburton one is and is sort of
complicated but what it comes down to is
that you have this contract called log
cap logistics civilian augmentation
program and it involves the outsourcing
of much of the US Army's support
basically wherever the US Army deploys
the contractor agrees to provide support
services there to feed house the US
troops help maintain their vehicles etc
that contract itself was competitively
bid out and it was done and it was done
under a cost plus structure which is
basically in exchange for you being
willing to go wherever we go we as a
military go we agree before it ever
starts to pay all your costs and to
guarantee you a minimal profit and then
we'll will essentially have a
arbitration process over what the other
profit level will be usually it's
between 9 and 1 percent that part was
competitively bid out now where it gets
where the the smell test sort of gets
risky is before the Iraq war the scope
of that contract army logistics was
redefined to include first oil well
firefighting and then it was redefined
to include repairing an oil system and
then it was redefined to include running
the Iraqi oil system and that is where I
take issue with it because that part was
not competitively bid out and also is
something that's clearly not you
West army logistics and as the
comparison for what you could have done
is actually the rest of the
reconstruction process which we had what
was called an amended bidding process
which Beck tell one they won the
contract to repair the electricity etc
so the question is why did you include
the oil one under the army one the army
contract the logistics contract rather
than having a separate process they
would guard your interests and the irony
is Halliburton probably would have won a
separate bidding process because like
you say they're one of the dominant
players in the oil services field and
may well want it but we'll never know
because we didn't follow that and then
it gets a little more complicated later
on because they got caught in this
dispute between the government and one
of the representatives and so they then
said okay we're going to have a bidding
process in August August rolled around
and they didn't have the bidding process
they said okay we're gonna have it in
October and so now they are going to
have it in October but we're two billion
dollars worth of work already done and
so the irony is then that companies like
Bechtel are saying that's not fair which
is you know in some ways like the you
know the pot calling the kettle black
but it's sort of an evidence that the
process didn't work right hold it look
I'm sorry someone who hadn't spoken yet
yeah glasses so do you want thank you
for coming I just got back from Kuwait
and Iraq one of these
people helping the military and I think
you know you made a lot of good points i
think you're overstating the case a
little bit a lot of the contracts are
bid they go through a very usual
government process i'm going to
one-on-one and it was still on went
through all that there are performance
expectations that you have to meet or
checked on all the time in our case we
do have some we do have to answer to any
colonel in the Army answer so general
and so on we were trained to use weapons
before we went over and other at least
most of the team i was with would have
been happy to use them if need hey um so
i think you know i think you're
overstating it just a bit i think the
other thing just to think about from a
cost and efficiency perspective but as
this gentleman said I mean my only
conclusion is i mean you've laid out
this problem and my only conclusion is
in order to solve it okay yeah there may
be some other regulations you could put
in but it is you need a bigger military
because frankly you know i'm doing a
technical ite until a communications
work that I guess you know the military
didn't have somebody with 20 clusters of
experience handy and you know how much
does that cost well okay they pay me X
amount of dollars to do that but how
long does it take to take a soldier from
day one and to give him or her 20 years
of experience you know that's expensive
and it costs a lot of money to come up
with this end product it's not just me
walking in the door oh why do you cost
more than a colonel
a major or whatever so you know while
you're doing your cost efficiency study
I think you know that you might want to
factor that in this well and i will say
that i found the the troops or very well
trained in general and we're committed
and i think most of us contractors who
were over this are not there simply for
money if you're running a company you
have several stakeholders you have your
employees you have your customers you
have your shareholders and you have the
public at large that you and you're
responsible to all those things I'm
gonna go and answer here because we've
been told we have three minutes left no
one knows the bottom line is what I'm
saying I a hundred percent agree with
you it's not just the bottom line and
that's why you have to take into account
not only cost efficiency but also the
other roles and responsibilities what
troubles me is the ad hoc approach
towards contracting and accountability
on this in some cases like I said we
have good oversight and good bidding
processes and in other cases we don't
and that cuts across is dependent on the
agency that's doing the oversight
whether it's US Army CIA USAID but also
remember we're talking about an industry
that's global so for example the gotcha
drug cartel did not have the same
accounting and accountability that the
US Army Corps of Engineers did now the
second part is this well the only other
answer is a bigger military well know
and i'll actually use an example from
another administration to show how it
doesn't illustrate the Pooh it's not
just a partisan expand the army issue
the deployment of KBR employees in the
Bosnia situation meant that we didn't
have to call up 8900 National Guard
folks now that's not in terms of
expanding the military it was a
political decision that was made because
it was thought to be an operation that
you could carry out as long as you
didn't have the political cost of
calling up the guard so your choice you
had choices there
you could have not done the operation
you could have used the guard you also
could have expanded the force you also
could have used contractors so we always
have choices here we can't just sort of
wave our hands and say well the only
other thing to do is expand the military
which maybe is something you want to
consider but you have choices and then
if you are going to use the contractors
do it in a way that ensures good
accounting and good accountability and
protects not only for cost interests but
also a public interests I think we have
time for maybe one more or let me just I
think we should include now with the
television coverage why don't we
conclude now with the c-span coverage
and we thank you very much for covering
this event I think Peter will be
available to answer a few more questions
a little bit later but for now let's
conclude this and thank you very much
for coming
maybe it makes sense to give folks who
want to leave time to get up pw singer
is a security analyst at the Brookings
Institution corporate warriors the rise
of the privatized military industry is
published by Cornell University Press on
the web at Cornell press cornell edu